yo creo que hay dos escenarios
necesarios el de la balcanización que es
básicamente que ucrania como tú los
ujieres termine separada como ocurrió
con la entonces yugoslavia desde el 95
al 99 y que se conviertan en dos nuevos
estados muy pocos reconocidos y la otra
opción es que pase lo que ha venido
ocurriendo en los casos de aucas ya
osetia transnistria nagorno karabaj a
los que se conoce como como de
conflictos congelados y es clásicamente
esto ocurrió hace unos 12 13 años cuando
rusia reconoció la independencia a casa
y osetia y a partir de allí quedó como
un conflicto en puntos suspensivos pero
hoy me up casi año set ya son son
estados independientes reconocidos por
la comunidad internacional esto podría
pasar con lugar sin donestsk podría ser
una suerte de enclaves rusos en el
territorio ucraniano como lo es hoy acá
si hay usted ya sin necesariamente
convertirse en estados porque
acordémonos acá estamos hablando de unas
fronteras muy disputas y unos estados
todavía con unas complejidades
nacionales entonces yo pensaría que es
muy difícil pensar en esa a viabilidad
ninguna de las 2 descartó y todo depende
hasta dónde está dispuesta a rusia a
llegar militarmente y es que sólo quería
decir porque además también con crimea
después estás don es expuesta lugar
estamos hablando pues de todo el flanco
oriental
de ucraniano mauricio y entonces que
quería decir sí rusia pues puede ser más
ambiciosa y quisiera ir por más
hasta ahora no hay ningún indicio que
sugiera que rusia va a ir más allá del
lugar y donestsk insisto porque pues
básicamente es es muy pesado yo no veo
una anexión del total del territorio de
ucrania no significaría una catástrofe
para ucrania para europa para la propia
rusia que no va a tener forma de llevar
a cabo una operación militar legítima de
ese de ese de esa magnitud si el
argumento de rusia es que está
cometiendo un genocidio contra 4
millones de personas sobre eso
básicamente no tenemos pruebas lo que
corresponde con esa denuncia básicamente
es la defensa del lugar en sidor mets
que es insisto hasta donde se han
mantenido los rusos y las operaciones
militares parecerían hasta ahora guardar
coherencia con eso más allá me parece
que no hay indicios para pensarlo salvo
en el caso de que hay una respuesta
militar fuerte por parte de la otan o
por parte de ucrania y uno podría pensar
que las ambiciones rusas podrían incluso
extenderse